I'm so excited to talk with you guys
congrats on the final season of Jack
Ryan
um you know right off the bat with this
being the last season and having
personally watched all of them now which
are they're such explosive episodes I
was on the edge of my seat each time
um there's such a real sense of closure
so how do you feel um each of you about
how season four completes the Jack Ryan
story I'm personally extremely proud of
it I think that it was it's a
Bittersweet thing uh the end of this
show because
um you know the end of the show we
wanted the last season to be exciting
and thrilling for the audience but we
also wanted to acknowledge for the
people who have been with us in season
one acknowledge the culmination of these
relationships and these characters uh in
a very genuine way that would mean
something to them so that they were
involved in saying goodbye as well
um and I think that we we pulled that
off that was really really exciting and
clearly reflective of our uh
interactions in real life I mean saying
goodbye to these guys uh luckily I don't
have to in my real life
um I don't know Michael we're on the
fence but um but it's uh it's it's truly
been the greatest experience uh you know
of of career and Life to get to work
with these guys and um so see how season
four picks up from season three in which
there are consequences to Jack's actions
so John where is Jack heading this
season and what can we anticipate
um well I think for the first time Jack
realizes that um the gray area that
Greer taught him about
um is not always uh outside of uh the
um agency that this time it's inside the
agency and so I think there's a sense of
betrayal that Jack's
um wrestling with and so he's not only
trying to save the world but he's also
trying to save his ideal of what he
thought he was doing and who uh what
group he thought he was a part of and
making sure that there's still hope for
the the good people to come out on top
uh Wendell also interesting aspect this
season the relationship between Jack and
it has evolved but there's a bit of a
tug of war sort of you know relationship
for him in terms of you know having a
relationship with his son and I've
always felt like he is a bit of a dad
sometimes to Jack so I'm curious with
like you know that that Dynamic um
what's the challenge that he's facing
this year and what can fans expect well
through our research from the very
beginning uh talking to the real life
officers of uh the CIA they said that
the work can have a real strain on
family life in particular the consultant
that I've become friends with uh
told me his personal story of how two
marriages have fallen apart and it's uh
and I wanted to reflect that so and and
how uh the connection with your kids
estrained and um so knowing that that is
real and something that is very
authentic we wanted to make sure to
bring that into what we already were
taking to another level the threefold
action the intelligence and then the
humanity in the show I and add that with
the the family conflict it was a new
Dynamic to the fourth season uh and
final season for James yeah and Michael
um it's interesting because your
character is not an original Clancy
creation which means he can be anywhere
and maybe even in the spin-off I'm not
sure
um but how fun has it been to create
this personality from the ground up and
then evolve this relationship with Jack
and Greer oh it's it's been ending it's
been a blast it's been it's been such a
been such a treat
um and to create it together
um you know I I obviously didn't have
any any say in the beginning I was I was
hired and but the way that the the path
that that character took through season
two
buy the book CIA guy to the end of the
season where he's he's gone he leaves
his job because he knows what Jack wants
to go do is the right thing to do and
he's going to go do it with him
um and then we were able to you know
these guys can just kind of we we made
him what he became by the end of that
second season and it and it happened I
think organically with the relationships
that the three of us had sort of helped
shape that that character and so he's
been a lot of fun to play I can tell you
that mine too I did forever I feel like
this is also like a show where you guys
have such strong romances so I'm sure
this is gonna be something you're gonna
miss completely it's been so fun to see
that
um yeah before I do let you guys go um
John I'm such a huge fan of your writing
and your directing and I actually cannot
wait personally for imaginary friends
um it sounds so phenomenal and like
really interesting so I'm wondering if
you can share anything about that and
you know what's after imaginary friends
oh man I don't know what's after uh if
it was a idea I had about seven years
ago and and finally got to make it and
uh it is extremely personal it's a movie
that I made for my kids because I don't
think they're allowed to see a quiet
place Emily calls it pg40 you always get
to see it
um so I had to make a movie that they
could see um and I'm really really
excited about it I mean Ryan Reynolds is
as good as it gets in every single uh
way shape and form and this uh
incredible phenomen of an actress Kaylee
Fleming is in the movie and uh for me it
was just about
um what if we could tell a story about
uh these time capsules uh the imaginary
friends are adorable and all those
things but they're also time capsules of
your hopes dreams and Ambitions when you
were the most fertile of uh of a brain
and and it never goes away I think we're
told that we're adults instead of what
if you realize that you never stop being
a kid well that sounds amazing I can't
wait and again guys congrats on this
show I love this one so much I've
watched it since from the start with my
dad and my sis sister and we're just
obsessed so thank you for making
incredible yeah I'm a big fan of you
three so I wish you continued success
thank you so much